في الروايه الاسرائيليه هل هناك اي تبرير
او تفسير للجوء لهذه الطريقه في تصفيه
هؤلاء الشبان داخل
مستشفى داخل مستشفى تجاوز لكافه المحرمات
وعمليه ترهيب وترويع للمرضى والمصابين
وكذلك للعاملين داخل المستشفى الروايه
الاسرائيليه كما جاء عليها بيان الجيش
المشترك مع جهاز الامن العام الشباك
والشرطه انقو مشتركه من من الجيش وكذلك من
جهاز الامن العام الشباك ومن وحده اليمام
الوحده الخاصه في الشرطه الاسرائيليه نفذت
هذه العمليه من خلال التسلل الى داخل هذا
المستشفى وقد تخفى جنودها بالزي المدني
ثلاثه منهم كانوا يرتدون زي الاطباء
والممرضين اخرين كانوا يرتدون زي النساء
وغيرهم كان يحمل يرتدي زي مد مدني ويحمل
ايضا وكانه يحمل اطفالا هؤلاء جاؤوا
بسيارات مدنيه الى محيط المستشفى مدنيه
تحمل اللوحات الفلسطينيه ثم ساروا
واقتحموا دخلوا الى المستشفى بشكل عادي
وكانهم مواطنين عاديين او اطباء قادمين
للعمل توجه هذا الطاقم الفريق الى الطابق
الثالث تحديدا وقاموا هناك مباشره بابعاد
ممرضات ومواطنين تواجدوا ثم اقتحموا
الغرفه التي تواجد فيها الشقيقين باسل
وشقيقه اي
ايمن الثاني وقاموا وايضا محمد جلامه من
كتائب القسام باسل وشقيقه هم من سرايا
القدس وقاموا باغتياله مستخدمين المسدسات
الكاتمه للصوت بعد ذلك انسحبوا من داخل
المخيم وخرجوا الدعايه او الروايه
الاسرائيليه تدعي بان محمد جلامه وهو من
قاده كتائب القسام في منطقه جنين كان على
اتصال مع قياده حماس في الخارج وانه كان
يعد
مع في منطقه جنين لعمليه اجتياح بالهام من
عمليه طوفان الاقصى التي نفذتها كتائب
القسام في غلاف غزه في السابع من اكتوبر
الماضي وانه كان يعد لذلك وقد تم اغتياله
وكان يعد مع باسل وشقيقه ايضا لعمليه
قريبه جدا عمليه عسكريه وفق الادعاء
الاسرائيلي علما ان باسل هو مصاب منذ الث3
من اكتوبر من صاروخ اطلقته مسيره
اسرائيليه على مجموعه من الشبان في مقبره
مخيم جنين وقد اصيب باصابات وشظايا في
كافه انحاء جسمه وكان يعالج في المستشفى
الجيش الاسرائيلي يدعي انهم كانوا يختبئون
في المستشفى مع العلم ان باسل كان مصابا
وكان يحتاج الى مرافق الى جانبه لذلك
قاموا بعمليه الاغتيال الجديد في هذه
العمليه انها اولا تشكل سابقه في اعتداءات
جيش الاحتلال داخل الاراضي الفلسطينيه
تحديدا في الضفه الغربيه والامر الاخر انه
لم يعد لديه امامه محرمات تمنعه لا قوانين
دوليه ولا حمايه لمراكز صحيه ولا حمايه
لمصابين وجرحى هؤلاء كانوا في المستشفى
وباسل معروف انه كان مصابا بمعنى ان جيش
الاحتلال في هذه العمليه انما يصعد من
عملياته في قلب الاراضي الفلسطينيه نحن
بسقوط الشهداء الثلاثه صباح او فجر هذا
اليوم يرتفع عدد الشهداء الفلسطينيين في
الضفه الغربيه منذ بدايه الحرب على غزه
التي دخلت يومها ال16 عش الى
381 شهيدا من بينهم 62 شهيدا منذ بدايه
العام الحالي وهما وخلال ال 24 ساعه بسقوط
الشهداء الثلاثه في مستشفى ابن سينا في
جنين يرتفع عدد
الشهداء خلال ال 24 ساعه الاخيره الى
ثمانيه يضاف الى هذا كله الى ان قوات
الاحتلال تواصل سلسله اقتحاماتها في كافه
ارجاء الضفه الغربيه وتشن عمليات اعتقال
تطال ايضا ذوي
وزوجات وامهات واباء واشقاء من تصفهم
بالمطلوبين لديها اي المقاومين
الفلسطينيين وحسب اخر او احدث احصائيه
لنادي الاسير الفلسطيني فان عدد حالات
الاعتقال منذ بدايه الحرب على غزه في
السابع من اكتوبر قد تجاوز
6300 عمليه اعتقال وهذا عدد هائل قياس
مع ما كان يجري في مرات سابقه وحملات
الاعتقال تمتد من اقصى شمال الضفه الغربيه
حت حتى جنوبها وهي متواصله في انحاء
مختلفه وكانت قد تركزت بشكل خاص هذه
العمليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه خلال
العامين الاخيرين تركزت بشكل خاص في منطقه
شمال الضفه الغربيه وتحديدا محافظه جنين
ثم انتقلت الى محافظه طول كرم وكذلك نابلس
وطوباس لكن تركز بشكل خاص على هذه المنطقه
والتي تواصل فيها عمليات اجتياح متواصله
وسط دعوات متجدده من قبل اركان حكومه
اليمين المتطرف في اسرائيل بضروره العوده
والاستيطان في المستوطنات الاربعه التي
كان قد تم اخلائها في عام في تموز عام خ
25 في اطار عمليه الانفصال على غزه وهذا
ايض ايضا امتداد لما كان قد اقدم عليه
قاده هذه الحكومه وهذه التوليفه امس الاول
في مؤتمرهم الذي يدعو الى الترحيل
الفلسطينيين من قطاع غزه والاستيطان من
جديد هناك
وتهجيرهم استخدموا عباره تهجيرهم طوعا ليس
هناك انسان يهاجر طوعا الناس او طواعيه
الناس تهاجر مجبره وهم يريدون التسبب في
تهجيرهم وبناء مستوطنات غير مكترثين لا
لمحكمه العدل الدوليه ولا لحقوق
الفلسطينيين حتى في الحياه يعني وليد وانت
تتابع هذا المشهد منذ
عقود ما تفسيرك لحدوث هذا المشهد غير
المسبوق الان في الضفه ولجوء قوات
الاحتلال لهذا
الاسلوب هذا اولا تجاوز لكافه المحرمات لم
يحصل من قبل في الضفه الغربيه هو حصل في
قطاع غزه فقط خلال هذه الحرب عندما بدات
تستهدف المستشفيات مثل ما جرى في الشفاء
وناصر وغيرها وما يجري في الضفه الغربيه
حاليا بانهم يقومون باقتحام مستشفى وشن
عمليه
اغتيال ويشنون عمليه اغتيال على هذا النحو
لمصاب داخل المستشفى ومن كان معه في
الغرفه مؤشر على ان قوات الاحتلال لم تعد
تكترث ولم تعد تضع اي محرمات امامها تحترم
ايه قوانين لحمايه مثل هذه المؤسسات